supongamos que me dan un triángulo que
tiene lados b
ve que vale 12 unidades tiene una
longitud de 12 unidades también me dan
el lado c
este aquí va a ser el lado ce que mide 9
unidades y me piden encontrar el lado a
que es este lado de aquí y a es lo que
tengo que encontrar ahora bien si no me
dicen nada más entonces el problema no
tiene solución porque podría acercar a b
y así llegamos cerrar este ángulo y
entonces a sería un número muy chico
pero si por el contrario lo que hago es
abrir este ángulo entonces puedo hacer a
un número más grande así que necesito
conocer este ángulo y vamos a suponer
que me dicen que teta que es este ángulo
de aquí vale 87 grados 87 grados muy
bien entonces como podría resolver esto
pues afortunadamente yo conozco la ley
de cosenos para un triángulo y lo que me
dice la ley de cosenos es que si conozco
dos lados del triángulo el ángulo entre
ellos entonces puedo encontrar el valor
del tercer lado y como lo hago pues
fórmula de la ley de cosenos me dice que
la longitud de al cuadrado es igual a la
longitud debe al cuadrado más la
longitud de sea al cuadrado y esto hasta
aquí sería como el teorema de pitágoras
lo que hace la ley de cosenos es darnos
un término de corrección para que se
aplique a cualquier triángulo entonces a
de cuadrada más se cuadrada le tengo que
restar dos veces el producto de la
longitud de b por la longitud de c
por el coseno el co seno de el ángulo
entre ellos por el cose no detecta y
trata tiene que ser el ángulo que abre
hacia el lado a si tuviera este ángulo o
este ángulo no me serviría de
absolutamente nada pero bueno entonces
vamos a sustituir por lo que ya conozco
tendría pues que a cuadrada es igual a b
al cuadrado pero b vale 12 así que ve al
cuadrado de 144 144 más si al cuadrado
que es 9 al cuadrado más 81
81 - 2 por ejemplo anotó todo 2 por 12
x
por 9
por el cose no el coseno de 87 grados
bien entonces cuánto vale esto entonces
a cuadrada va a ser igual a 144 más 81
que cuánto sería sería 225 déjenme vamos
a usar este color 225 menos 2 por 12 es
24 por 9 sería 216
en los 216 por el coseno de 87 grados
ricoh seno de 87 grados
ok y ahora si voy a tener que usar la
calculadora pero antes déjenme
escribirlos y no va a ser igual a la
raíz cuadrada de 225 menos 216 por el
coseno de 87 grados esa va a ser la
longitud de a
pero cuanto vale eso pues saco mi
calculadora
seco que esté en grados
y 100 grados
y pongo quiero encontrar la raíz de 225
menos 216 por el coste no el coseno de
87 grados
y cuánto es eso pues es 14.61 8
así que
vale
14.61 8 y ya acabamos esa es la longitud
del lado